Hello and welcome to a special bonus episode of How We Made Your Mother.
大家好，欢迎收看《我们如何创造了你的母亲》的特别奖励剧集。
We like to call these general questions.
我们喜欢称这些为一般性问题。
General questions?
一般问题？
Who I heard an extra voice on there.
我听到那里有一个额外的声音。
Who was that?
那是谁？
It's me.
这就是我。
I've decided not to leave.
我决定不再离开
If we can't get rid of it, we keep saying just click off.
如果我们无法摆脱它，我们就会一直说“点击关闭”。
Shut the laptop.
关闭笔记本电脑。
Is this our first ever guest on the general questions?
这是我们第一位回答一般性问题的客人吗？
General questions.
一般问题。
Very exciting.
非常令人兴奋。
Chris, thanks for being here.
克里斯，谢谢你来到这里。
Chris wrote game night episode 15, which we did a great discussion on that a couple of days ago.
Chris 编写了《游戏之夜》第 15 集，几天前我们对此进行了深入的讨论。
And Chris is back to answer all your questions and dispel his memories.
克里斯回来回答你所有的问题并消除他的记忆。
He's wearing the same shirt.
他穿着同样的衬衫。
We're always the same clothes as a few days ago.
我们的衣服总是和前几天一样。
We've been under the redidender.
我们一直在重定义者之下。
It's the redidender.
这是重新定义者。
We had so much to catch up on.
我们有很多事情要赶。
We haven't met the computers since Monday.
从星期一开始我们就没有见过电脑了。
All right.
好的。
So, Alec, what do we got?
那么，亚历克，我们得到了什么？
Here we go.
开始了。
So one of our one of our biggest supporters, not our biggest or the show's biggest supporters Swarly memes has a lot to say and So Swarly means I'm sure you're listening to this.
因此，我们最大的支持者之一，而不是我们最大的支持者或节目最大的支持者 Swarly memes 有很多话要说，So Swarly 意味着我确信您正在听这个。
I hope that currently this is being clipped like right now I'm in a Swarly meme that would be incredibly exciting and Swarly meme says Chris Harris That's the mini cherry on top of the regular cherry on top of the Sunday of awesomeness that is this podcast and then And I'm just going to read this lovely note to Chris with the question at the end.
我希望现在这个被剪掉，就像现在我在一个斯沃利模因中一样，这将是非常令人兴奋的，斯沃利模因说克里斯·哈里斯这是在常规樱桃之上的迷你樱桃，在这个播客的令人敬畏的周日之上，然后我只是要读给克里斯这篇可爱的便条，并在最后提出问题。
Chris, what I love about your episodes is how we always find ourselves in silly situations like game night, club night, award night, concert night, removing tattoo, fixing a car, hippie wedding venue, effed up, house or subway, but they still have so much heart and force the characters to reveal their true selves or grow into a better person.
克里斯，我喜欢你的剧集的一点是，我们总是发现自己处于愚蠢的境地，比如比赛之夜、俱乐部之夜、颁奖之夜、音乐会之夜、去除纹身、修理汽车、嬉皮婚礼场地、情绪低落、房子或地铁，但他们仍然有那么多的心，迫使角色展现真实的自我或成长为一个更好的人。
Because in the end, it's not those silly moments with the people we love dearly that we remember, not the big weddings and whatnot.
因为归根结底，我们记住的不是那些与我们深爱的人在一起的愚蠢时刻，也不是盛大的婚礼之类的。
So to turn that into a bit of a question, Chris, can you just because you do these larger episodes often going all the way up to subway wars and that size, can you start putting together the scope versus the character?
所以，把这个问题变成一个问题，克里斯，你能不能仅仅因为你拍了这些更大的剧集，经常一直到地铁战争和那么大的规模，你能开始把范围和角色放在一起吗？
Yeah, I'm torn between such a lovely compliment and also like being exposed for having a very simple formula for everything I've ever written.
是的，我在这样可爱的赞美和被揭露之间左右为难，因为我所写的所有内容都有一个非常简单的公式。
I don't know.
我不知道。
I don't know if I think of it as, you know, it's always, you know, how much a mother was always great about these are the big moments in this person's life.
我不知道我是否认为，你知道，母亲总是对这些是这个人生命中的重要时刻感到多么伟大。
And that's the virtue of the perspective of the dad talking to his kids years later is like, we have an excuse to skip over the small things and talk about like, this is when I started dating this person.
这就是父亲多年后与孩子们交谈的观点的优点，就像，我们有借口跳过小事并谈论类似，这就是我开始与这个人约会的时候。
This is when these two broke up.
就在这时，两人分手了。
This is when this person returned.
就在这个时候，这个人回来了。
And so I think the big events go along with that, and they're always, they're always fun to put people in, to put characters in a new situation, obviously, just to see how they'll react.
所以我认为大事件也随之而来，而且它们总是很有趣，让人们置身其中，让角色处于新的情境中，显然，只是为了看看他们会如何反应。
But no, I feel lucky that I got to write a lot of these, especially in these early seasons.
但不，我觉得很幸运，我写了很多这样的内容，尤其是在这些早期的季节里。
You know, Carter and Craig came in with the idea about the club.
你知道，卡特和克雷格提出了关于俱乐部的想法。
They came in with Barney and Game Night.
他们带着巴尼和游戏之夜进来了。
So it was a lot of fun to play with those worlds that the characters got to jump into.
因此，玩角色要跳入的世界非常有趣。
It's also like there are big events and how I met your mother, but you could make the argument that every episode is a big event or he wouldn't be telling the story.
这也就像有一些重大事件以及我如何认识你母亲，但你可以说每一集都是一个重大事件，否则他就不会讲这个故事。
Yeah.
是的。
It feels like if he's telling it, it lingered for him and it also shaped him.
感觉如果他说出来，这件事就会萦绕在他的心头，也塑造了他。
When we pitched the show, we pitched like it's the 100 best stories of your 20s and 30s, hoping that we'd hit 100 episodes and then we did 208.
当我们推介这部剧时，我们把它当作 20 多岁和 30 多岁的 100 个最佳故事来推介，希望能达到 100 集，然后我们做到了 208 集。
So that back 100 Nate, we're just more like B minus, C plus.
所以回到 100 Nate，我们更像是 B 减，C 加。
But it's also like the, is it Gene Shepherd who you keep referring to the critical story?
但这也就像，你一直提到的批评故事是吉恩·谢泼德吗？
Yeah, Gene Shepherd.
是的，吉恩·谢泼德。
Yeah.
是的。
It's the pineapple incident.
这就是菠萝事件。
We talk a lot about like Ted is mythologizing his life, you know, he's like, we all do, right?
我们经常谈论泰德把他的生活神话化，你知道，他就像，我们都这样做，对吧？
We're all the main characters in our stories and what are the things you'll remember 25 years from 2005?
我们都是故事中的主角，从 2005 年起 25 年后，您会记得哪些事情？
And that was the test of season one of the show.
这就是该剧第一季的考验。
And I think Game Night was a good one because it's so eventful.
我认为游戏之夜是一个很好的活动，因为它非常多事。
It raises the bar on how eventful and memorable you have to try to make things in the show because he has to remember it in the future.
这提高了你必须在节目中做出多么重要和令人难忘的事情的标准，因为他必须在未来记住它。
And I love that notion, Josh, like Ted's mythologizing his own because I do feel like that's such a part of it is, you know, even the re-returned, like giving these names to these events.
我喜欢这个概念，乔什，就像泰德将自己的神话化一样，因为我确实觉得这是其中的一部分，你知道，即使是重新回归，就像给这些事件起这些名字一样。
The re-returned, yes.
重新回来了，是的。
Very Jean Shepherd, making the events.
非常让·谢泼德（Jean Shepherd）制作了这些活动。
It's a historical document, right?
这是一份历史文件，对吗？
It's like the Battle of Valley Forge.
这就像福吉谷之战。
And also the kind of coded language that friend groups develop.
还有朋友团体开发的那种编码语言。
You know, you have this kind of Patois.
你知道，你有这种方言。
Craig, Sarah had this question a few weeks ago and it fits nicely now of like, you know, the Supreme Court, if the chief justices is in the majority, they get to choose who writes the opinion.
克雷格，莎拉几周前提出了这个问题，现在很适合最高法院，如果首席大法官占多数，他们就可以选择谁撰写意见。
You and Carter obviously got to choose who writes each episode was Chris at a certain point chosen for a certain scope, a certain kind of episode.
显然，你和卡特必须选择由克里斯在某个时间点为特定范围、特定类型的剧集编写每一集的人。
And in general, how did you decide how many you guys would write and how many you would give away?
总的来说，你们是如何决定你们要写多少以及要捐出多少？
Boy, I mean, in season one, I can't say there was much of a formula that was more just like keeping our head above water and stuff.
天哪，我的意思是，在第一季中，我不能说有太多的公式更像是让我们的头保持在水面以上之类的东西。
And I think, you know, Chris, I think you were three of them in season one.
我想，你知道，克里斯，我认为你是第一季中的三个人。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
I did, yeah.
我做到了，是的。
And I'd say that that's because we knew Chris would kill it.
我想说那是因为我们知道克里斯会杀掉它。
You're excited to give a guy like Chris an episode because you know it's going to come in really good and you're not not need to have late nights on that one.
你很高兴能为像克里斯这样的人制作一集，因为你知道它会非常好，而且你不需要为此熬夜。
At that point, we had never run a TV show before.
那时，我们以前从未经营过电视节目。
So at that point, I can't say it was anything more than this was a big one.
所以在这一点上，我不能说这是一件大事。
We're learning who Barney was.
我们正在了解巴尼是谁。
It had to advance the story in the present while showing us who Barney was in the past.
它必须推进现在的故事，同时向我们展示过去的巴尼是谁。
High degree of difficulty, give it to Chris.
难度很高，交给克里斯吧。
I think that was part of the, so it was a compliment to Chris, for sure.
我认为这是其中的一部分，所以这当然是对克里斯的赞美。
But it also felt to me like in the arc of who was writing what, it always felt like the first episode was a you and Carter, the finales were you and Carter, and one or two in the middle were you and Carter, right?
但对我来说，就像谁在写什么的弧线一样，总是感觉第一集是你和卡特，结局是你和卡特，中间的一两个是你和卡特，对吧？
Yeah, more than one or two, we usually did, because there were two of us, and we could, one guy could still be running the day to day of the show, and the other guy could peel off and write one, and it was sort of like, that's how we do it, one of us would sort of mostly do one episode and then the other, but both our names were on it.
是的，我们通常会做不止一两个，因为我们有两个人，我们可以，一个人仍然可以每天主持节目，另一个人可以剥离并写一个，这有点像，我们就是这样做的，我们中的一个人主要做一集，然后是另一集，但我们两个的名字都在上面。
Yeah, it's really like a Lennon McCartney situation, right?
是的，这真的很像列侬·麦卡特尼的情况，对吧？
Like McCartney wrote Blackbird, but it's a Lennon McCartney song.
就像麦卡特尼写的《黑鸟》一样，但这是一首列侬·麦卡特尼的歌曲。
Yeah, except like a much worse Lennon and McCartney.
是的，除了更糟糕的列侬和麦卡特尼。
Like them, but nowhere near as talented.
和他们一样，但才华远不及他们。
So that kind of gives you the scope.
所以这给了你范围。
And everyone's all, I come in with my octopus's garden.
大家好，我带着我的章鱼花园进来了。
And it's great to have you here, Ringo.
很高兴你能来到这里，林戈。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Here comes the sun, motherfucker.
太阳来了，混蛋。
Here comes the sun.
太阳来了。
That's Chris Harris.
那是克里斯·哈里斯。
Come on.
快点。
Don't.
不。
But by the way, I hope this is Garden's fucking great, too.
但顺便说一句，我希望《花园》也很棒。
No one's losing out here.
这里没有人会失败。
We love you, Ringo.
我们爱你，林戈。
But no.
但没有。
But yeah, Carter and I, yeah, we would sort of mostly take one or the other, but it would always kind of go through the other guy first and say, hey, add some awesomeness, or sometimes help dig me out of a problem on this.
但是，是的，卡特和我，是的，我们大多会选择其中之一，但总是会先经过另一个人，然后说，嘿，添加一些很棒的东西，或者有时帮助我解决这方面的问题。
So we would each weigh in on each other's episodes.
所以我们每个人都会对彼此的情节进行权衡。
But over time it became more like Carter ran a room, I ran a room and then we sort of tripped.
但随着时间的推移，情况变得更像是卡特管理一个房间，我管理一个房间，然后我们就绊倒了。
So it was like that.
事情就是这样。
But Chris, we would have given Chris this episode with Great Glee knowing it was a really important big one.
但是克里斯，我们会给克里斯这一集《欢乐合唱团》，因为我们知道这是非常重要的一集。
Okay.
好的。
So a lot of questions, Chris, from the fans, we were talking about the fact that fans, especially ones who came to it later or binging it, they get the whole series as a book that they just read all at once.
克里斯，粉丝们提出了很多问题，我们谈论的是这样一个事实：粉丝们，尤其是那些后来才看到或狂饮的人，他们把整个系列当作一本书，一次性读完。
Whereas you're making it as a newspaper, right?
而你却把它做成报纸，对吧？
to sort of make you one every day and hope that if you see a fire truck in one episode and seven years later there's another fire truck where you're planning on there being two fire trucks you right they kind of see all of that.
让你每天都看到一辆消防车，并希望如果你在一集中看到一辆消防车，七年后又出现另一辆消防车，而你计划有两辆消防车，你是对的，他们会看到所有这些。
So there's a couple of questions on that.
所以有几个问题。
I just want to talk about in the large this notion of big how much you were looking at big picture planning ahead or that you were just treading water.
我只是想从大的方面谈谈这个大的概念，你是在多大程度上着眼于未来的大局规划，或者你只是原地踏步。
For example in drum roll please season one episode 13 Barney he picks up a bridesmaid saying he's going to be away for two years with the Peace Corps.
例如，在《请打鼓》第一季第 13 集《巴尼》中，他接了一位伴娘，说他将离开和平队两年。
Was that foreshadowing of this episode or did you just think about it as a callback or are you not noting it until I literally I'm saying it to you right now based on your thoughts.
这是这一集的伏笔吗？还是你只是将其视为回调，或者你没有注意到它，直到我现在根据你的想法对你说这句话。
Can I can I recover and say it was all planned?
我能恢复过来并说这一切都是计划好的吗？
I have no recollection of that, but we were there were there were pretty close together.
我不记得了，但我们在那里的时候距离非常近。
So I wonder we owned it.
所以我想知道我们拥有它。
I think we thought we do we thought that Barney had some like the ingredients for that lie were based on some part of who he used to be.
我想我们认为我们确实认为巴尼的谎言的成分是基于他过去的某些部分。
I think we I think we did own it or we liked that that sort of echoed that.
我想我们确实拥有它，或者我们喜欢这种呼应。
I think I think that was semi-intentionally.
我想我认为这是半故意的。
It's also funny to consider like if she quizzed him on the Peace Corps, he'd be able to ace it.
想想如果她问他关于和平队的问题，他一定能取得好成绩，这也很有趣。
He would know how to answer those Questions, yeah.
是的，他会知道如何回答这些问题。
Yeah, I think that was a tunnel.
是的，我认为那是一条隧道。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，是为了在纽约唱给你听。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 HyperFixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts, or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客，或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
We talked about this a little bit on the main episode, but just to go over to the game, because a lot of people talked about the board games.
我们在主要情节中对此进行了一些讨论，但只是为了讨论游戏，因为很多人都在谈论棋盘游戏。
A lot of people talked about the board game and the least father, Terri O.D., So to, oh, by the way, I want to give to that previous question that was Gabborn, Gabborn 15.
很多人谈论棋盘游戏和最少的父亲，Terri O.D.，所以，哦，顺便说一句，我想回答之前的问题，即 Gabborn，Gabborn 15。
This is Terio D02.
这是特里奥 D02。
Was this knowingly the beginning of Marshall's love of making board games throughout the series?
这是马歇尔在整个系列中对制作棋盘游戏的热爱的开始吗？
And if so, who or what was the inspiration of this character trait?
如果是这样，这个性格特征的灵感来自于谁或什么？
Where did this come from?
这是从哪里来的？
Yeah.
是的。
Well, I mean, we talked about it in the main episode of the main podcast episode.
嗯，我的意思是，我们在主要播客剧集的主要剧集中讨论过它。
I think it was a lot of Chris.
我认为克里斯有很多。
There was a lot of Chris in there, Chris loves stuff like that, right?
那里有很多克里斯，克里斯喜欢这样的东西，对吧？
I mean, that was you.
我的意思是，那是你。
I don't know if I had the original notion that Marshall is great at games and makes up his own games.
我不知道我是否有最初的想法，认为马歇尔擅长游戏并创造了自己的游戏。
I think that might have just been a room thing, but I definitely jumped on that in terms of like, oh, I can write this.
我认为这可能只是一个房间的事情，但我肯定会跳起来，就像，哦，我可以写这个。
You love that world's disentine in a very intricate, like.
你喜欢那个世界的错综复杂，喜欢。
I bet I can get it.
我打赌我能得到它。
It sounds tough, but I bet I can get inside the head of someone who likes games and puzzles.
这听起来很难，但我打赌我能进入喜欢游戏和谜题的人的头脑。
It's gonna be really difficult.
这真的会很困难。
Well, you really made that stretch, Chris.
好吧，克里斯，你确实做到了这一点。
I really was really brave, Leeve.
我真的很勇敢，利夫。
Isn't it funny to consider, though, in the first season of something, if you think, okay, one of these characters is obsessive about board games, you could kind of make the case that any of them could be, or conversely, any of them hated board games.
不过，考虑一下，在某件事的第一季中，如果你认为，好吧，其中一个角色对棋盘游戏着迷，你可以说他们中的任何一个都可能是，或者相反，他们中的任何一个都讨厌棋盘游戏，这不是很有趣吗？
Like, you were still assigning things to people.
就像，你仍然把事情分配给人们。
Oh, totally, yeah, Robin's super competitive, so she's super into games, or really- Or Robin hates board games, she can't stand them.
哦，完全，是的，罗宾非常有竞争力，所以她非常喜欢游戏，或者真的 - 或者罗宾讨厌棋盘游戏，她无法忍受它们。
She had an incident in high school with board games, scarred her, you know, Ted, you could very clearly see being in board games, you know?
她在高中时与棋盘游戏发生了一起事件，给她留下了伤痕，你知道，特德，你可以非常清楚地看到棋盘游戏，你知道吗？
It does echo, it echoes with bass guy's ball a little bit.
它确实有回声，它与贝斯手的球有一点回声。
Like the idea of Erickson's invent weird games.
就像埃里克森发明奇怪游戏的想法一样。
It echoes with that, I don't remember if that was intentional, but it does a little bit.
与此相呼应，我不记得这是否是故意的，但确实有一点。
That's a great point.
这是一个很好的观点。
But yeah, to Josh's point, like at the beginning of a season of a show, like that's both the exciting thing.
但是，是的，对于乔什来说，就像在一季节目开始时一样，这都是令人兴奋的事情。
You can assign anything to anyone, but it's also the scary thing because you don't know, you don't like later on, oh, Marshall, you know, who wants to be a God parent?
你可以把任何事情分配给任何人，但这也是可怕的事情，因为你不知道，你不喜欢以后，哦，马歇尔，你知道，谁想成为上帝父母？
We know that Marshall loves games, this makes sense.
我们知道马歇尔热爱游戏，这是有道理的。
And so we have this information about these characters that we can extrapolate and build further stories from, but there's a lot of blank slate at the beginning of a show.
因此，我们拥有有关这些角色的信息，我们可以从中推断并构建进一步的故事，但是在节目开始时有很多空白。
So it's...
所以这是...
No, in the writer's room, is it just like a collective hive mind memory?
不对，在作家的房间里，是不是就像是集体的蜂巢记忆？
Are the writer's assistants like the gatekeepers of like, no, you can't do that because you have this?
作家的助手就像看门人一样，不，你不能这样做，因为你有这个？
Like, how does that work?
就像，这是如何运作的？
Writer's assistants are very helpful in that regard.
作家的助手在这方面非常有帮助。
We had really good ones on our show and they go, wait a second, no, you said this earlier.
我们的节目中有非常好的节目，他们走了，等一下，不，你之前说过这一点。
I was so, what was great is anyone on staff could do that though.
我就是这样，很棒的是，任何员工都可以做到这一点。
You know, like hair and makeup could say that.
你知道，就像发型和化妆一样。
Dave Baker and props could say that like, everyone cared for the intricacy of this universe we were creating the kind of world building component that I think we got those notes and those good catches.
戴夫·贝克和道具可以说，每个人都关心这个宇宙的复杂性，我们正在创建一种世界构建组件，我认为我们得到了这些注释和那些好的捕获。
And sometimes those clever pitches, sometimes you go down to the set and either set deck or Dave or whatever, had added things in based on character traits from earlier episodes, seasons, years before, and you come and you go, You remembered this, you know, there's a lock in his monster thing, you're banging in a room and it's just like a really funny, subtle joke, you know, that's all that's props that's set dressing.
有时那些巧妙的投球，有时你去片场，无论是片场还是戴夫或其他什么，根据早先的剧集、季节、几年前的角色特征添加了一些东西，你来了又走，你记得这一点，你知道，他的怪物东西上有一把锁，你在一个房间里敲打，这就像一个非常有趣的、微妙的笑话，你知道，这就是布景装饰的所有道具。
That's like a lot of the time the writing had nothing to do with those touches.
就好像很多时候写作与这些接触无关。
And it was just how genius the larger creative team was on the show.
这就是节目中更大的创意团队的天才之处。
So the I have a good conversation started to end us in the next question.
因此，我们聊得很好，下一个问题就结束了。
But the penultimate question here is definitely the one that had the most questions on Instagram.
但倒数第二个问题绝对是 Instagram 上提问最多的问题。
And again, it goes to how much you know, um, I think it's like the George Lucas version of it that he knew a lot of this.
再说一次，这取决于你知道多少，嗯，我认为这就像乔治·卢卡斯版本的那样，他知道很多。
He had this plan, but oh, did he really have that plan?
他有这个计划，但是哦，他真的有这个计划吗？
And this and that.
还有这个和那个。
And then there's the, I know the Vince Gilligan version of writing where he really always talked about, we had no idea.
然后是，我知道文斯·吉利根的写作版本，他总是谈论，我们不知道。
We just kept writing ourselves in the corners.
我们只是一直在角落里写下自己。
We need nothing that was going next.
我们不需要接下来发生的任何事情。
We'd write a cold open to something.
我们会写一份冷开封信。
We did know what we're we're going to pay off.
我们确实知道我们将得到什么回报。
We only have some, you know, so the question is, okay, says star brace smoothie.jpeg and so many other people.
你知道，我们只有一些，所以问题是，好吧，star括号smoothie.jpeg和许多其他人说。
I've been waiting for this.
我一直在等待这个。
Who gave Robin the mat is a Ted or Barney.
给罗宾垫子的人是特德或巴尼。
This question has plagued me for years.
这个问题困扰了我很多年。
Oh, interesting.
哦，有趣。
That's an interesting thing.
这是一件有趣的事情。
I don't take it as a question.
我不把它当作一个问题。
It's interesting because I never, it never crossed my mind that it could have been someone other than Ted.
这很有趣，因为我从来没有想过这可能是特德以外的人。
Oh, we're talking about the Cherbotsky welcome method.
哦，我们正在谈论切尔博茨基欢迎方法。
Yeah, I didn't think I thought it was Ted.
是的，我没想到我认为这是特德。
I thought I forgot something 100% Ted, 100% Ted.
我以为我忘记了什么 100% Ted，100% Ted。
This was Ted making a nice gesture that actually plants an interesting seed of what's going to happen with Ted and Victoria moving forward.
这是泰德做出的一个很好的举动，实际上为泰德和维多利亚的前进埋下了一个有趣的种子。
I think I really liked that moment, but it was for sure, Ted.
我想我真的很喜欢那一刻，但这是肯定的，特德。
But I also thought that it could have been Robin until it was the reveal of Victoria that gave Ted the plastic vomit.
但我也认为可能是罗宾，直到维多利亚的揭露让泰德吐出了塑料呕吐物。
You're right.
你说得对。
Right.
正确的。
And that could have been her, but it's also a nice, you know, day taunts, is that the word?
那可能是她，但这也是一个很好的，你知道的，白天的嘲讽，是这个词吗？
Like it's a piece of their weirdness.
好像这是他们怪异的一部分。
Yeah, the last we saw was that awkwardness.
是的，我们最后看到的就是那种尴尬。
And then it's like, okay, where it seems, it seems like they're getting passed.
然后就好像，好吧，看起来，他们似乎已经被超越了。
I really liked how awkward that moment was, by the way, where and Barney's like, you were right, Ted, you really shouldn't have told that story.
顺便说一句，我真的很喜欢那一刻的尴尬，巴尼说，你是对的，特德，你真的不应该讲那个故事。
That was, that was a good like literally just swimming in that awkwardness and it doesn't really get resolved except for that, that moment in the montage.
那是，这很好，就像在那种尴尬中游泳一样，除了蒙太奇中的那一刻之外，它并没有真正得到解决。
But that moment of resolution is important.
但下定决心的那一刻很重要。
we had to reconnect head in Victoria to deepen them in the next couple of episodes.
我们必须重新连接维多利亚的头部，以便在接下来的几集中加深它们。
And that little moment between them is really important.
他们之间的那一刻真的很重要。
It's a great song to do that in my morning jacket song off record.
这是一首很棒的歌曲，可以在我未录制的早晨夹克歌曲中做到这一点。
Great, great indie rock, needle drop.
很棒，很棒的独立摇滚，针尖掉落。
And that is important because we need to care about and invest in Victoria because what's to come between them is going to be the main narrative in the next couple of episodes.
这很重要，因为我们需要关心并投资维多利亚，因为他们之间发生的事情将成为接下来几集的主要叙述。
I really like that little moment between them.
我真的很喜欢他们之间的那一刻。
And I remembered one little breaking the story thing that I could throw in really fast, which was, at one point in the room, when Carter and Craig were not away, there was this extra twist that was added where it was like, oh, Barney actually, this actually was an audition tape, and Barney faked being part of the part, you know, this whole story just to get Ted to tell the re-return.
我记得有一点打破故事的事情，我可以很快地投入进去，那就是，在房间里的某个时刻，当卡特和克雷格不在的时候，有一个额外的转折，就像是，哦，巴尼，实际上，这实际上是一盘试镜带，巴尼假装成为这个角色的一部分，你知道，这整个故事只是为了让特德讲述重播。
And it was so smart to like, no, of course not.
而且喜欢真是太聪明了，不，当然不喜欢。
That's too much.
那就太多了。
It breaks the story.
它打破了这个故事。
It's this naked, it's tail, yeah.
这是赤裸的，是尾巴，是的。
Yeah, and it's like, it's too much.
是的，这就像，太多了。
And I feel like that was a learning experience for me, which is like, no, let's live in this.
我觉得这对我来说是一次学习经历，就像，不，让我们生活在这样的环境中吧。
This is the reel of how Barney was.
这就是巴尼的真实写照。
And I don't know, I just remember thinking, oh, wow, that was such the right call.
我不知道，我只记得我当时想，哦，哇，这是一个正确的决定。
I completely forgot about that.
我完全忘记了这一点。
Yeah, it was like an extra twist.
是的，这就像一个额外的转折。
And we're like, oh, no, now it's just all madness.
我们就像，哦，不，现在这一切都是疯狂的。
It's a hat on a hat.
这是一顶帽子上的一顶帽子。
It must be a hat on a hat.
一定是帽子上的帽子。
When you guys think it must be fun to watch these episodes because in your mind, you might actually think, No, that did happen because it happened in the writer's room and you forget, you forget where it landed.
当你们认为观看这些剧集一定很有趣时，因为在您的脑海中，您实际上可能会想，不，那确实发生了，因为它发生在作家的房间里，而您忘记了，您忘记了它落地的地方。
Chris, I'm just now remembering that you and I had a bit that lasted almost all nine seasons.
克里斯，我现在才想起来，你和我的经历几乎持续了整个九季。
Wasn't the bit that I thought you were lying about having gone to Stanford?
我以为你在斯坦福大学就读的事情不是在撒谎吗？
Yes, you had a, in fact, I had, hold on, I had, I, I, I, I wondered if you were going to bring that up.
是的，你有，事实上，我有，等等，我有，我，我，我，我想知道你是否会提起这个。
So I said, when will Josh use the phrase back when I was at Stanford?
所以我说，当我在斯坦福大学时，乔什什么时候会使用这个短语？
which was, which was, which is like, but I guess 1326 in on the original.
这是，这是，这就像，但我猜原来是1326。
Oh my god, that was a bit, that was a bit, it was a bit, that I said that you were always saying, starting to sit back when I was at Stanford.
天啊，那是一点，那是一点，那是一点，我说你总是这么说，当我在斯坦福大学的时候就开始袖手旁观了。
And then it evolved into, I don't think you actually went to Stanford.
然后它演变成，我不认为你真的去过斯坦福大学。
Yeah, that became, yeah, come on, what you, what, you don't, it was something like, you don't need to say this to me, I'm not, you know, try to impress me.
是的，这变成了，是的，来吧，你什么，什么，你不，就像是，你不需要对我说这个，我不是，你知道，试图给我留下深刻的印象。
And I remember you kept going like, no, I really didn't go there.
我记得你一直说，不，我真的没有去那里。
I did, I went there.
我做到了，我去了那里。
Yeah, I know, because you say back when I was at Stanford all the time.
是的，我知道，因为你总是说我在斯坦福大学的时候。
But the idea that Chris had the guest pre-written on, like, sort of like a newly-wet game style card.
但克里斯让客人预先写在上面的想法，就像是一张新湿的游戏风格的卡片。
It's like Johnny Carson's Envelope.
就像约翰尼·卡森的信封一样。
It's the absolute great con act.
这绝对是伟大的骗局。
Like, with the fact that Chris just did that, Chris was just Marshall in this episode.
就像克里斯刚刚这么做的事实一样，克里斯在这一集中只是马歇尔。
Yeah.
是的。
Chris was just the game master.
克里斯只是游戏大师。
He held up.
他坚持住了。
He had a guest of the time.
当时他有一位客人。
That was full.
那已经满了。
That was Marshall.
那是马歇尔。
And it didn't even occur to me until right now we've been talking for a long time.
直到现在我们已经聊了很长时间，我才意识到这一点。
I know, I'm flattered.
我知道，我受宠若惊。
I'm flattered, it didn't come up earlier.
我很受宠若惊，它没有早点出现。
There's a deeper thing at play, which is the writers and the actors got to know each other and were friends and really like symbiotic, it was a symbiotic relationship, you know?
还有更深层次的事情在起作用，那就是编剧和演员互相认识，成为朋友，真的很喜欢共生，这是一种共生关系，你知道吗？
Absolutely, yeah.
绝对是的。
And then stories went back and forth and things that actors, that stories came out of things that happened on stage.
然后故事来来回回，演员的故事来自舞台上发生的事情。
It was awesome.
太棒了。
And just to say, not to sound too back in my day or too like pro-union guy, this is what the writer's guild was striking for, in part, right?
只是想说，不要听起来太回到我那个时代，也不要太像支持工会的人，这就是作家协会罢工的部分目的，对吗？
The idea that writers should be on shoots, writers shouldn't pre-write things and then disappear and then it's shot and they're separate.
编剧应该参与拍摄的想法，编剧不应该预先写好东西，然后消失，然后拍摄，他们就分开了。
The actors and the writers getting to know each other actually impacts the final part.
演员和编剧的相互了解实际上影响了最后的部分。
And when Chris was on his day for his own episodes, he would come up with all lines that were hilarious and made it into the episodes.
当克里斯在他自己的剧集中时，他会想出所有搞笑的台词并将其纳入剧集中。
I remember I would accuse you, I would say, you would say, back when I was at Stanford, Do you think Ted has to cross on that line, or should he cross on that line?
我记得我会指责你，我会说，你会说，当我在斯坦福大学的时候，你认为特德必须越过那条线，还是他应该越过那条线？
I was like, Chris, you didn't need to say back when I was in Stanford.
我当时想，克里斯，当我在斯坦福大学的时候，你不需要说回来。
I really don't think I said that.
我真的不认为我说过这样的话。
I can't believe we're having this argument again.
我不敢相信我们又发生这样的争吵。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, Chris, we're delighted we have the door is open.
好吧，克里斯，我们很高兴门是开着的。
Please come back and talk about how I made it by the way again.
请回来顺便说说我是怎么做到的。
When I think about how I made your mother, your face is on the Mount Rushmore.
当我想到我是如何创造你母亲时，你的脸就在拉什莫尔山上。
So thanks for being here.
感谢您来到这里。
Despite the snamford wire.
尽管有斯南福德线。
I am guilty, please equip me, all sins are forgiven, in New York City.
我有罪，请装备我，所有的罪孽都被宽恕，在纽约。
How we major mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何成为母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并监制。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, at Point of Blue Studios, and our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves，我们的数字内容制作人（又名 Z 世代大师）是 Emily Blumberg。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《NYC》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to sign up for our Substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 注册我们的 Substack 邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些商品吗？
Click on the store link, or go to howyougetyourmerch.com.
单击商店链接，或访问 howyougetyourmerch.com。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Mews Letters on Substack, order Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasRider.com slash novel, and you can subscribe to my Dead Father Society also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 的 Mews Letters，在 CraigThomasRider.com 斜杠小说上订购克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 的处女作，您也可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《死去的父亲协会》(Dead Father Society)。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解您如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持下才得以实现的。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。